[Musique]
bonjour nouveau débat sur tv soixante
dix huit radio sensations pour le
premier tour de ces élections
municipales 2020 débat aujourd'hui
consacré à maurepas il y a plusieurs
listes déclarées à 100 ce 9 février
deux de ces listes déclarées ont accepté
de venir participer à cette émission
celle de grégory gary astier maire
sortant ancien membre des républicains
aujourd'hui sans formation politique
dont la liste se veut ouverte
bonjour à vos aisselles 10 miles havane
également déjà candidat par le passé
également sous les couleurs du parti
socialiste aujourd'hui vous aussi vous
mener une liste que vous souhaitez
ouverte
bonsoir bonjour et bienvenue sur ce
plateau pas forcément sur des couleurs
du parti au pouvoir
je précise que toutes les listes
déclarées ont été sollicités pour
participer à cette émission la campagne
officielle dans les médias et ont débuté
le 3 février le dépôt des listes est
impossible jusqu'au 27 de ce mois ci en
préfecture les choses peuvent encore
évoluer
chacune d'entre elles bien évidemment un
temps de parole équivalent qui sera
accordé bonjour donc à vous d une
nouvelle fois au cours de ce débat je
vous rappelle que le temps de parole est
chronométré et nous débutons avec ce
premier tour de table
et cette question pourquoi les électeurs
vous devrez voter pour vous pourquoi
vous présentez une nouvelle fois ismaila
va nous débutons avec vous ainsi en a
décidé le tirage au sort juste avant le
début de l'émission bonjour à vous donc
effectivement merci de cette
présentation donc je suis conseiller
municipal d'opposition dans le groupe
maurepas dynamique et solidaire et dans
la vie civile je suis ingénieur et
créateurs d'entreprise donc c'est pour
la présentation et je me suis écarté du
parti socialiste depuis deux trois ans à
peu près et je conduis je suis à la tête
fut tête de liste de d'une liste
pluraliste donc sans étiquette qui est
ouverte à tous alors nous ce que nous
faisons et je fais le pari de
l'intelligence collective avec un large
rassemblement d'hommes et de femmes qui
vont oeuvrer ou ont déjà oeuvré pour un
idéal supérieur et la création d'un
projet pour tous et ce projet a pour
condition de répondre aux enjeux majeurs
de notre époque et surtout de d'amener
mort pas vers la modernité sur la
transition écologique par exemple qui
est notre adn
nous on ne peut pas se contenter de ce
qui a été fait actuellement par
majorité actuelle nous sommes des
militants de la cause écologique et
c'est vraiment viscérale chaque jour sur
l'extinction de masse à laquelle nous
vivons ça nous touche au plus profond de
nous et nous pouvons pas laisser des
choses comme ça il nous souhaitons avoir
un projet vraiment orienté sur la
transition écologique et que nous
puissions porter ces valeurs et sur la
démocratie nous avons la volonté d'une
nouvelle gouvernance qui est la
modernité où le citoyen est prise à
partie dans les décisions de la vie de
la cité
voilà pourquoi nous nous présentons non
pas pour un parti ni pour une ambition
personnelle mais vraiment parce que nous
avons des choses à faire en tant que
militant de la vie de la cité
restez vous êtes le maire sortant élu en
2014 pour la première fois nouvelle
candidature pour 2020 pourquoi les
électeurs devraient faire confiance à
tout d'abord remercié votre invitation
une confiance que j'ai eus par les
électeurs en 2014 la volonté du
changement l'alternance et aujourd'hui
vous le savez un monde assez six ans
c'est court et je m'inscris dans la
durée avec un travail profond de
modernisation des services publics que
j'ai engagée avec mon équipe
au travers d'un aménagement durable avec
la réussite des enfants
la rénovation du patrimoine bâti puisque
j'ai récupéré aussi un héritage assez
lourd en ce sens où il n'y avait plus
d'investissements dans le patrimoine
mais aussi dans la tri de transition
écologique
or monsieur van disais tout à l'heure
qui fait les plus loin bien sûr qu'il
faut aller plus loin mais on a fait déjà
beaucoup de choses puisque on est parti
aussi de loin donc cette volonté
toujours d'être dans un état d'esprit
positif et constructif d'être dans la
continuité la réussite des enfants la
tranquillité des habitants mais aussi de
transformer durablement notre belle
ville de maurepas avec je le crois
l'avenir de paris-ouest que
nous conduisons avec mon équipe et aussi
avec la ville de coignières au travers
du projet repenser la périphérie
commerciale
voilà pour ce premier tour de table nous
allons passer aux thématiques de ce
débat juste après ce sujet qui revient
sur quelques uns des enjeux concernant
la ville donc de maurepas c'est un sujet
qui a provoqué de nombreux remous sur la
précédente mandature en avril 2015
centre nautique de maurepas reste porte
close
son état d'usure et mis en avant pour
justification un site sportif qui
accueillait 170 mille utilisateurs par
an dont 40 mille scolaires des communes
de maurepas et l'encours et coignières
après de nombreux recours fait par
l'opposition le contrat de délégation de
service public a été signé le 6 janvier
2020 le projet doit sortir de terre en
une zone d'activités bientôt six zones
d'habitat paris ouest à cheval sur nos
repas et coignières va progressivement
changer de visage
un écoquartier de 800 logements
continuent de voir le jour
la première pierre du projet a été
symboliquement déposée en avril 2018 où
les vertes central des places de
stationnement matériaux biosourcés ou
encore domotique dans les logements
la résidence de maricourt doit être
livré fin 2020 le projet complet devrait
lui prendre fin à l'horizon 2030 et des
constructions pour augmenter le taux de
logements sociaux mort pas en compte
actuellement 17 5%
la loi oblige les communes en avoir 25 %
un bétonnage présenté comme trop
importants par l'opposition autre enjeu
qui concerne plusieurs communes
carrefour de la maldonne attendu pour
2026 le réaménagement du site prévoit
son enfouissement la verrière maurepas
et coignières actuellement séparés par
la nationale 10 seront ainsi relier
voilà pour quelques-uns des sujets qui
vont occuper cette campagne à maurepas
nous allons essayer de revenir à même
d'élargir encore la discussion nous
débutons par la question de l'urbanisme
du renouvellement urbain pour l'évoquer
tout d'abord un sujet qui a fait
beaucoup parler pendant ce mandat c'est
la piscine l'ancien centre a été fermé
la carie n'était plus aux normes le
choix de la destruction et effet plutôt
que celui de la rénovation
la livraison devrait se faire en 2022
on va débuter avec vous grégory gary
astier puisque vous avez un tout petit
peu moins de temps de parole aujourd'hui
le projet est sur les rails
il sortira en deux
22 aujourd'hui le contrat de délégation
de service public avec eiffage et récré
a été signé le 6 janvier dernier avec le
maire d'elancourt puisque nous avons
fait le choix de reconstruire un centre
aquatique intercommunal
un projet ambitieux et j'en suis fière
même si on a perdu beaucoup de temps
quand même à cause aussi de procédure
juridique interminable un plus de dire
aux cours au tribunal administratif
et aujourd'hui les habitants ont été
pris en otage et le sont toujours
quelque part avec un projet qui coûtera
moins cher qu'auparavant puisque
auparavant c'était 1,2 million d'euros
par an sur les comptes de maurepas mais
à demain ce sera à 7 730 1000 euros sur
25 en fonctionnement et investissement
compris avec un équipement qui répondra
à toutes les générations et notamment
aussi en priorité à l'apprentissage des
scolaires puisque sandy classe par
semaine seront accueillis
donc voilà on est lancés sur le dossier
le permis de construire est en cours
d'instruction et j'alerte puisque le
permis sera signé après les élections
municipales ou pas en tout cas les
électeurs ont la garantie qu'avec le
renouvellement de leur confiance ils
auront leur centre aqualudique en 2022
et la vanne sur ce dossier du centre
aqualudique tel qu'il est appelé
aujourd'hui si vous êtes élu vous irez
jusqu'au bout vous reviendrai sur ce
projet alors déjà sur le projet de la
piscine
il faut corriger si vous permettez ce
que vous dites sur le fait que les
recours ont retardé le projet de la
piscine c'est complètement faux et je
vous demande de vous expliquer sur le
fait que des recours et retarder le
projet ce que c'est complètement inventé
alors sur ce projet ce qui est risqué
c'est que ce projet se transforme
finalement ne p r de maurepas c'est
notre inquiétude puisque c'est un
serpent de mer
mais pour être pour être vraiment
concret moi je crois que ce projet a mis
en valeur qu'un certain nombre de
dysfonctionnements et de carences qu'il
faut corriger
la première d'entre elles c'est sur
l'état d'esprit
l'état d'esprit c'est que ce sujet a été
politisée par des caricatures qui
devrait pas avoir lieu par exemple sur
le fait que moi est en compte de gauche
je j'ai aucun problème là dessus que je
serais contre le privé parce que c'est
la tendance de la gauche d'être sur le
privé ce genre d'argumentation doit être
pallié ma proposition sur ce genre de
projet et à l'avenir sur des projets
aussi importants pour mort pas c'est que
c'est une commission qui soit paritaire
soit créée et qu'elle rassemble les élus
de l'opposition les élus de la majorité
et aussi des citoyens experts parce que
nous avons la chance à hambourg quoi
d'avoir des citoyens experts qui ont
travaillé sur ces sujets qui connaissent
le dossier est en même temps a ajouté
par un tirage au sort les citoyens à
cette commission pour qu'ils puissent
contrôler parce que la démocratie c'est
aussi du contrôle et la transparence
un autre répond après il ya les i je
vous en prie je vous laisse terminer
puis je lui rends passerelle à paris un
autre point qui mérite je pense d'être
améliorée et qui est un des facs
dysfonctionnement c'est la démocratie
moi j'ai ici le rapport 2009 qui a
conduit à la destruction et la
reconstruction de la piscine
il est en ligne je vous mets au défi de
montrer de démontrer noir sur blanc que
veritas qui a pignon sur rue a écrit une
quelconque dangerosité sur cette piscine
jamais jamais org un local où aucun
organisme de l'état montre de nous
jamais un organisme de l'état n'a fait
référence à cette dangerosité
je trouve cela très grave et nous a
empêchés potentiellement d'avoir une
orientation différente mais il ya aussi
un autre axe d'amélioration qui me
semble important c'est l'écologie
voyez vous nous sommes dans un moment de
la transition écologique et il faut
raisonner sur l'impact entre
déconstruire et reconstruire et
réhabiliter à l'avenir ensuite il ya un
aspect financier sur lequel je vais
revenir
vous prenez beaucoup avancé en viendra
aux questions de démocratie d'écologie
environnement collection dîner bah voila
j'aimerais plus qu'à y aurait gagné si
vous le souhaitez vous puissiez répondre
à aux différents points qui ont été
abordés sur la dangerosité sur les
consultations qui ont été menées sur la
reconstruction est par contre
je vous proposerai aussi la question
esmael havane si vous êtes élu est ce
que vous arrivez ce projet vous
arriverez à l'envoyer on est dans la
démonstration typique de ce qui s'est
passé pendant quatre ans et demi c'est à
dire une opposition stérile où on
n'arrive pas à s'entendre et s'étaler
différence d'être un opposant politique
et d'être aux responsabilités
l'audit qui avait été fait en 2009 qui
est avec avaient été cachés par l'équipe
précédente que j'ai découvert je les
fais réédité par deux autres organismes
qui disait bien que l'équipement était
dangereux pour le public
donc à partir de ce moment là moi je
prends mes responsabilités parce
qu'après c'est le maire qu'on vient
chercher donc j'ai fait fermer
l'équipement parce qu'il était dangereux
pour le public et ensuite la question se
posait de savoir s'il fallait
réhabiliter ou reconstruire la
réputation était possible sauf qu'elle
coûtait plus cher
elle coûtait plus cher d'autant plus
qu'il est bien un équipement sportif en
france ou en tout cas qu'il faut plutôt
reconstruire que rénover ce sont les
piscines parce que ça touche à l'air ça
touche à l'os à tous à tous les éléments
aujourd'hui je ne regrette absolument
pas mon choix puisque en tire un
équipement qui coûtera beaucoup moins
cher qu'avant
d'autant plus qu'il sera neuf et
entretenue pendant 25 ans ce qui n'était
pas le cas et grâce au choix que nous
avons fait nous avons obtenu 11,6
millions d'euros de subventions
publiques
sur les 24 millions d'euros du projet et
après monsieur van vous ne parlez de
démocratie locale
je rappelle que c'est vous qui avait
alimenté la polémique depuis le départ
vous avez contester mon choix et vous
l'avez politisé donc j'étais obligé
aussi de répondre sur le terrain
politique et à partir de ce moment là
une guerre juridique a été engagé qui a
fait perdre du temps à l'administration
pour les mais bien sûr que je peux le
prouver qu'elle attendait le juge a
suspendu le projet je termine le juge
n'a pas fait suspendre deux d'ailleurs
vous avez une grenade et à 2300 euros
d'amendé rateront dascon avant son achat
en revanche sur ce sujet nous avons
perdu beaucoup de temps et d'énergie
parce que l'équipement devait être
reconstruire reconstruite par groupe et
saint quentin en yvelines
on a perdu beaucoup dans wild ans
l'administration à quel endroit le
respect messieurs le monsieur van vous
parlez aussi de démocratie locale avait
levé des faits monsieur van vous parlez
aussi de démocratie locale
vous hésitez toujours opposé à la
reconstruction donc aujourd'hui vous
souhaitez arrêter le projet où vous
l'avez dit faut vous l'avez dit faut se
taire et et de projets tour donc
aujourd'hui on ne sait quel équipement à
quoi ci dessous monsieur m'a mise en
place la police d'après sur le cycle est
juste sur la démocratie locale
on n'a pas pu travailler ensemble depuis
le début de ce projet parce qu'ils ont
toujours été opposé une reconstruction
et que quoi qu'on faisait tout était
alimentée politiquement dans des tracts
qui disaient le contraire de ce qui
avait été dit au conseil municipal à
partir de ce moment là la discussion des
plus possible ismaila vans et je
souhaitais revenir encore sur ce sujet
thématique donc on va pas faire toutes
les missions sur un dossier de me disant
que l'humanité a dit écoute là toute la
tout le débat mais ce qu'il dit est
complètement faux moi je veux des
éléments factuels écrit à aucun moment
le dossier n'a été stoppé par une
quelconque décision judiciaire c'est
complètement faux donnez nous le papier
prouvez le vous n'êtes plus capables jeu
fermé le temps additionnel je termine
les perdre du temps administrateurs
mines et en plus vous critiquez aussi
des agents communaux qui sont compétents
parce que vous faites référence à des
experts à l'extérieur de la ville
or il ya des agents communaux qui sont
quand même compétent pour travailler sur
ces dossiers là donc ça veut bien dire
que c'est pas confiance aussi
l'administration on l'entend
effectivement lorsque la majorité et 5
et un problème de démocratie fournir est
en capacité de fournir tous les
documents nécessaires pour qu'on puisse
étudier le sujet on n'aurait pas fait
appel
un expert en berne avait plus que père
j'ai d'abord je n'avais plus que par ma
joie demeure aussi sur la conduite de ce
dossier terminer je vous propose la
question parce que j'aimerais qu'on
avance sur ce dossier là où il ya
beaucoup à dire et j'entends bien de
barils au-dessus n'ayant pas sur ce
point qu'elle en fait si vous êtes élu
sur l'île et droz heureux pour nos
finances d'ailleurs votre adjoint aux
finances le dit lui même il rejoint
l'opposition que nous que nous avons dit
depuis deux ans rencontré votre adjoint
aux finances rennes plus dit que c'est
pas son choix et que cette décision met
en péril les finances de la municipalité
avec une augmentation de 30 % de taxes
foncières article les nouvelles de
versailles donc nous si nous sommes élus
qu'est ce que nous allons faire nous
allons ouvrir construit une piscine
contrairement à ce qu'il dit jamais nous
avons nouveau évoqué l'idée de ne pas
contractuelles et nous avons été les
premiers
créé et une pétition pour demander la
réouverture partielle très tôt donc nous
sommes pour vous faites par la cuisine
actuelle sera donc maintenant ce que
nous voulons faire nous ces deux rues de
là bas si c'est doré négocié le contrat
à rennes nous ferons tout en oeuvre pour
qu'ils soient à taille humaine il ya
taille raisonnable pour les finances de
la ville bat mm ce qui nous importe
c'est deux choses
construire une piscine et qu'elles
soient financièrement supportable pour
les mort pas dire non je vais vraiment
la moitié de cette émission et on avoir
des fesses de ses juges de clôture sur
ce match sera dirigé donc on comprend
bien que monsieur val n'y aura pas de
piscine parce que de toute façon le
contrat a été signé neuf et deuxièmement
mon adjoint aux finances aujourd'hui à
voter tous les les textes et notamment
la dernière délibération du 17 décembre
dernier il n'y aura pas évidemment
d'augmentation de la fiscalité locale
puisque l'équipement est financé par les
recettes des nouveaux habitants qui vont
arriver souvent parler aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui j'en perds un renouvellement
de ma liste et je peux comprendre qu'il
ya des déceptions mais en tout cas c'est
l'avis moi j'avance nous poursuivons ce
dossier de l'urbanisation plus
généralement on en arrive vous parler de
ces nouveaux logements justement une
partie de l'opposition parle de de trop
de constructions entre bétonisation pour
reprendre les termes qui sont utilisés
quels seraient vos projets on va
commencer avec vous il se mêle à vannes
car vous avez un peu d'avancé donc du
coup j'ai passé la parole à grégory gary
ce thème et sur ces différents chantiers
est-ce qu'il ya encore à construire plus
aujourd'hui quelle serait votre
politique pour le prochain mandat
alors on parle beaucoup d'environnement
et d'écologie et bas nous nous sommes
passés aux actes et là j'attends aussi
au tournant l'opposition sur ces sujets
là parce qu'en 2014
quand je suis arrivé aux responsabilités
nous avions que 14 % de logements
sociaux et vous le savez la loi impose
25% du nombre de résidences principales
en logements sociaux
donc nous avons réviser le plan local
d'urbanisme nous avons sécurisé les
terres agricoles et naturelles de
maurepas nous avons aussi interdit la
construction sur le terrain des fermes
de la partie du village
le parc du bout des clauses d'un
constructeur bhl les terrains de tennis
municipaux l'hygiène de la morte hier
l'emprise même de la hague du marché
voilà pour éviter de concerts du
logement sur ces parcelles là et nous
avons souhaité engager un renouvellement
urbain dans la zone d'activités paris
ouest ce qui nous a valu d'ailleurs à
d'avoir le soutien de l'état dans le
projet repenser l appareil sphère
commerciale d'aujourd'hui
moi ce que je refuse c'est de faire 100
% de logements sociaux par opération
parce qu'on parle de bétonnage mai
les logements sont pas faits rend pas il
ya ou en carton c'est du béton
sauf que nous engageons le
renouvellement d'un quartier où il n'y
avait pas de logement et à la place
d'entreprise qui était désaffecté depuis
longtemps donc aujourd'hui on préserve
les quartiers existants avec un plan
local d'urbanisme qui a été votée en
septembre dernier et on engage le
renouvellement urbain dans paris ouest
en répandant à nos obligations d'état ce
qui nous vaut quand même trois cent
mille euros damende par an ce conte à
verser 1,2 million d'euros depuis le
début du mandat
donc maintenant j'attends de savoir
est-ce que vous souhaitez déverrouiller
ce que nous avons fait et construire
village et densifier cette partie du
territoire que nous ne souhaitons pas en
tout cas de mon côté ou continuer les
logements dans paris ou est-ce qu'il
faut répondre à nos obligations
je ne souhaite pas densifier comme vous
le dites le village et je n'ai jamais
dit règlement vous les faits tout
laisser parler on a une approche qui est
complètement différente
avant de construire ont réfléchi puisque
aujourd'hui la construction en fait de
ce quartier amène un certain nombre
d'impacts l'origine sur le transport sur
le transport oui qui a qu'il faut qu'il
faut dimensionné sur les équipements
collectifs et puis le plus important
c'est que le fait de loger un endroit
c'est pas forcément habiter c'est aussi
vivre et donc du coup la question en
fait de l'urbanisme se règle aussi par
ses comptes repasser par ces
problématiques et le fait de recréer du
lien entre l'existant est ce qu'il ya
aujourd'hui donc nous notre proposition
effectivement c'est d'eux que ce
quartier soit relié à la ville parce que
c'est nécessaire et nous souhaitons
aussi un aménagement du cr détresse
parce que il a été pensé ce ce quartier
pour la voiture
or nous sommes dans des logiques
complètement différente où nous devons
utiliser de moins en moins la voiture et
donc du coup réfléchir avant c'est de
penser la circulation c'est de penser ce
qui fait vie avec les collectifs avec
les instruments de collectivités social
de lien social qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui et donc du coup nous avons
une approche complètement différente
donc nous si nous sommes vos
responsabilités dans un premier temps
nous allons geler cela pour poser cette
réflexion et que gelée
logement vous faites comme moi que
l'état pour que le quartier aujourd'hui
fassent sens deuxième mais les fait
comment mais je n'écris tarn 2e clément
votre argument sur les logements est une
arnaque logements sociaux en irak les
chiffres résidence des coudrais qu'a été
construit des logements sociaux tout à
fait résidence bienville 250 logements
50 logements sociaux 288 logements 235
changements sociaux au fait le résultat
oui le chiffre que je que je dis les
morceaux pourront le vérifier
oui ce qui se passe avec ce rythme là
c'est que au global on va construire des
logements sociaux mais on va qu'on sera
tellement à côté que les quarts en
pourcentage de logements sociaux
au final va diminuer fatalement donc
votre argument de dire que je construis
pour diminuer la dette je suis désolé
qui ne tient pas la route et donc du
coup il faut densifier
il faut densifier je pense le centre
ville parce que nous pensons qu'ils
avancent au rythme et au sérieux vannes
vous allez voir vous connaissez très mal
votre ville il ya encore des poches que
nous souhaitons régler avec
densification de la ville tout en
préservant parce que c'est notre adn que
les zones boisées de notre ville d
abidjan 15 minutes de temps de parole
vous pouvez répondre les magasins du
centre-ville vont être contents de
savoir que vous souhaitiez densifier le
centre-ville
en revanche moi je tiens quand même à
contrecarrer les arguments parce que
aujourd'hui et c'est vraiment une grande
différence qu on est entre nous qui est
une différence idéologique
nous ne souhaitons pas faire 100 % de
logements sociaux
oui en effet on fait de l'accession 65%
la session sur iberville ses 280
logements et 35 % de logements sociaux
et on opère un renouvellement urbain
donc vous êtes en train de me dire alors
donc on va penser les routes et les
infrastructures et après on va
construire
donc je pense que le préfet va pas être
d'accord d'ailleurs un article de actuel
soit 118 activia d'annoncer que joueur
pour chartrain n'était plus en carence
parce qu'ils ont donné des gages de
bonne volonté
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui peut se passer
si on ne respecte pas nos orgueils nos
engagements très élevé dans ces cas là
effectivement c'est l'essai et qui
reprend la main
et nous respectons nos engagements
triennaux puisque nous avons 200
logements sociaux net à construire tous
les trois ans nous les respectons mais
dans une mixité sociale accession à la
propriété renouvellement partie sociale
après je tiens quand même à rassurer je
pense que le delta est trop grand et le
tessin 95 anglais rattraper ils ne
détectent robot vous avez vu je refuse
de faire 100 % de logements sociaux dans
les ensembles
après justin surgelés sumadija c'est
tout ce que je vous ai dit c'est que le
delta est beaucoup trop grand vous ne
pouvez pas contre une résidence avec
zéro logements sociaux une autre
résidence à 250 logements avec seulement
cinq ans non mais je valide pas d'accord
vous savez pourquoi dans la résidence
des coudrais 28 logements à la 10ème et
en accession parce que nous l'avons dit
au plan local d'urbanisme
nous sommes à proximité des friches où
il y a déjà 100 % de ces maux sociaux et
donc nous souhaitons avoir de la mixité
c'est ça la différence que nous avons
entre nous après je tiens aussi à
apporter des éléments statistiques que
mes fans je crois ignore depuis 2011
nous avons une baisse de plus de 4% de
la population 700 habitants en moins
nous avons une chute des naissances de
30% nous avons si nous nous construisons
pas de logements d'ici 2029
nous avons l'équivalent de 11 classes
élémentaires qui fermerait et quatre
classes de maternelle qui fermera et
aujourd'hui même avec les nouveaux
logements qui arrivent notamment l'école
de la tour n'a que six enfants qui sont
inscrits et on a 40% et maurepas bien
qu' on a acheté dans les nouveaux dans
les nouveaux ensembles donc nos
équipements sont totalement adapté nous
avons tout prévu dans une prospective on
n'y va pas comme ça absolument pas nous
avons une perspective très clair que
nous avons mené avec saint quentin en
yvelines depuis quatre ans avec des
chiffres clairs avec des hypothèses
hautes de fréquentation tous les
équipements seront adaptés nous l'avons
inscrit dans un plan pironet
l'investissement d'aujourd'hui nous
devons engager le renouvellement urbain
dans paris ouest construire du logement
mais en faisant de la mixité
je refuse de 100% social pour équilibrer
si vous souhaitez réagir sur ce sujet
après nous passerons une autre
thématique vous avez une vingtaine de
secondes lui cette caricature
personne n'a parlé de construire 100 %
de logements sociaux nous nous sommes
dans une de la mixité sociale aussi et
les 25 % de logements sociaux répartis
sur tout le territoire tout là toute la
ville et surtout les quartiers
moi je vous dis non au regard des
chiffres que je viens de vous donner à
l'écologie
environnement des sujets qui se
retrouvent sur les différentes
thématiques mais qui tiennent à coeur
aux candidats dans les différents
programmes si on les relit on va débuter
avec vous ismaël havane quelles sont vos
propositions dans ce sens là vous voulez
une transition écologique notamment avec
un agenda 25 qui était lancée oui
interlocuteur pourquoi pourquoi dans
l'introduction j'ai dit qu'il y avait un
manque de prise en compte de la
transition écologique parce qu'il existe
un agenda 21 qui était ce qu'il était
mais qui avait le mérite d'exister dans
l'ancienne majorité à laquelle je
n'appartenais pas et qui avait eu cette
bonne idée de lancer cet agenda 21
cet agenda 21 nous nous souhaitons leur
prendre leur sort renforcée et le mettre
au coeur de notre programme pour que la
transition écologique c'est un
changement de modèle économique et
social que nous souhaitons mettre en
oeuvre est aussi un changement de
gouvernance pour que les habitants
soient partie prenante sur tous les
projets que reçoit la piscine que ce
soit la construction d'un écoquartier
qui n'est pas un écoquartier ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui donc
propositions concrètes mais ce que nous
souhaitons mettre en place c'est une
commission de la transition écologique
qui soit gérée par le premier adjoint
dans laquelle les habitants auront leur
place puisque nous ferons un tirage au
sort pour les habitants pour qu'ils
puissent s'investir delà de la cause
publique ça me semble important les
jeunes via comité des jeunes que nous
allons créer et nous souhaitons aussi
créer une maison des associations que
vous aviez promis mais qui sera aussi la
maison de la transition écologique pour
donner un endroit de résidence à toutes
ces associations merveilleuse qui sont
sur un mort pas je pense au vrai parc a
fait qu'ils puissent avoir un endroit où
exercer et en même temps un endroit
qu'ils fassent le lion pour la formation
auprès des habitants pour trouver de
l'information sur tout ce qui concerne
la transition écologique d'un organe si
on n'est pas d'accord et ce qui a été
dit si j'en crois vos expressions tout
d'abord l'agenda 21 nous notre label a
été renouvelée par l'ensemble des
actions que nous avons mis en place plus
d'une quarantaine d'actions dans notre
bilan pour l'environnement parce que je
rappelle aussi que c'est une philosophie
c'est une politique que nous menons et
je regrette que monsieur van d'ailleurs
s'est opposé à tous les projets
d'investissements qui ont permis aussi
de faire des économies d'énergie je
pense à la rénovation des écoles à la
rénovation des squares on a on
réintégré vous êtes opposé au budget on
a réintégré de la nature en ville c'est
que l'on n'arrive absolument donc on a
on a rénové les causes de la jirama
termine vous entendez pas c'est moi
terminer monsieur van où vous racontez
nous votre expression et à la rénovation
des écoles notamment ses de la géo de la
marnière qui permet de faire des
économies d'énergie aujourd'hui monsieur
viennent bien essayé de nous proposer un
tirage au sort avec une maison de
l'environnement qui existe déjà sur
saint quentin en yvelines avec des
actions que saint-quentin pilotes déjà
donc ça veut dire une multiplication de
la dépense publique donc là encore ça
paraît
ce n'est pas responsable donc nous on va
continuer évidemment dans la transition
écologique avec aussi des ateliers
participatifs de sur ce sujet là mais
malgré tout nous proposons nous allons
proposer la semaine du développement
durable
nous allons proposer aux habitants de
mieux intégrer j'allais dire les serres
municipales pour apprendre les gestes
d'écologie urbaine
nous avons déjà installé pas mal de
potagers urbains
l'éco-quartier cliente en est un je
rappelle que la ville nouvelle ne s'est
pas fait en un jour
l'éco-quartier si une vision sur 15 ans
puisque ce sont des logements c'est un
parc urbain à terme c'est un espace
médical c'est une nouvelle crèche dont
évidemment il va y avoir des coutures
sur la ville et une vie dans ce quartier
puisque on en construit un nouveau comme
ça c'est fait avec jacques riboud à
l'époque dans les années 60
nous allons développer une ressourcerie
également comme opérait en yvelines nous
avons la volonté de créer un verger
urbain également dans l'un des quartiers
de mort pas de continuer notre politique
pour laver le véhicule électrique
ce que je rappelle que j'ai renouvelé
aussi la flotte une partie de la flotte
des véhicules municipaux en véhicules
électriques et de mettre des stations de
rechargement électrique pour les
habitants il y aura d'autres encore
projet vous souhaitiez en rivière tout à
l'heure oui donc
ça c'est une partie nos propositions
dans notre agenda 21 comprend 35 35
mesures que nous souhaitons mettre en
place que nous allons présenter le 27
février lors de notre réunion publique
donc je peux pas toutes les énumérer ici
mais l'état d'esprit est fondamental
c'est que la transition et que c'est une
implique une nouvelle gouvernance parce
que la transition écologique c'est une
affaire de tous si on veut que ça
fonctionne cela ne peut pas être réservé
à vos conseillers aux conseillers
municipaux à des organisations éparses
ici qui saupoudre pour moi et pour
montrer le fait qu'on fait de la
transition écologique alors que ça ne
l'est pas donc du coup notre ambition
est beaucoup plus grande et sur les
propositions que j'avais énoncés c'est
vraiment d'intégrer des habitants par
l'intégration aussi de comités de
quartier que nous allons créer par des
actions citoyennes organisées sur des
projets de transition écologique donc
notre dimension sur la transition
écologique elle repose vraiment sur
l'action citoyenne et la coopération du
citoyen ce qui nous amène sur le dernier
et thème de ce débat vous êtes à douze
minutes de temps de parole
ismaël havane et grégory est restée en
11 minutes 40 quasiment à égalité tous
les deux dernier thème solidarité
sociale on pourra aborder la question de
la santé aussi tout cela une fois de
plus se recoupent il n'y a pas de
domaine isolé et puis je le précise
c'est un débat qui aborde certains
points des programmes des candidats
je vous invite à aller les rencontrer
sur votre commune ou aller sur leur site
internet pour en savoir un petit peu
plus d'ici au 1er tour le 15 mars
grégory gars restée sur cette thématique
là vous évoquez le lancement d'une
mutuelle communal par exemple sur le
domaine de la santé des services aux
seniors aussi avec une résidence seniors
et même pour du lien au sein de la
population ait accès au restaurant
scolaire aux seniors pour le déjeuner
des enfants tout à fait en fait on a
deux axes sur la politique que je
conduis la continuité c'est un cadre de
vie en mouvement une ville pour toutes
les générations
vous venez de le dire toutes les
générations de la petite enfance
jusqu'aux seniors la construction d'une
résidence services pour les seniors qui
crée évidemment du lien et c'est un vrai
besoin pour notre population parce qu'on
a quand même 24 % de nos populations qui
a plus de 60 ans donc en centre-ville
c'est d'ouvrir les restaurants scolaires
également aux seniors dont nos actions
intergénérationnelles qu'on va également
multipliés au mille club puisque nous
avons déjà commencé et sur la solidarité
j'ai à dire j'ai aussi un bilan dire que
j'ai augmenté sous le grand de mon
mandat de 65000 euros la subvention au
ccas qui nous permet aussi d'aider
davantage les populations fragiles parce
que nous avons une précarité aussi
grandissante de nos populations et il
faut les aider au quotidien à payer les
factures de cantine et d'énergie donc le
seces aide en ce sens mais c'est aussi
les actions intergénérationnelles les
actions pour les seniors avec de
renforcer les animations seniors pour
évidemment lutter contre l' isolement
nous souhaitons créer également une
navette municipale pour emmener les
seniors les jours de marché mercredi
matin et samedi matin et continuer
également nos efforts sur la santé je
pense qu'on en parlera quelques instants
ismaila vannes vous évoquer ce dossier
pour la résumer plus de justice sociale
c'est ce que vous voulez mettre en place
sur cette commune en fait le la
solidarité c'est un ensemble de petites
choses qui font solidarité par exemple
les colonies de vacances
lilly 1 comme le mulot qui permettent
de relations et de tisser du lien social
c'est un ensemble de petites choses qui
sont assez importantes qu'il faut
préserver qui ont été surpris mais pour
certaines et qu'il faut remettre parce
que c'est ça qui fait le lion et qui
crée de du lien social donc ça c'est
notre premier objectif sans remettre ce
lien social par un certain nombre de
mesures qui ont été complétés supprimés
sur l'intergénérationnel je vous rejoins
puisque c'est dans le cadre de notre
projet et on souhaite ça rejoint aussi
l'habitat faire des réserves foncières
pour comment dire répondre à la question
de l' isolement de nos habitants parce
que beaucoup sont son ag à maurepas et
beaucoup vivent seules et si une
préoccupation pour nous qui est très
importante donc recréer du logement
collectif en associant les intérêts les
différentes générations
c'est dans notre dans notre proposition
comme celle là était en 2014 et nous
souhaitons avancer sur ce sujet je
souhaiterais juste rajouter sur la
solidarité mais c'est van dyck est des
choses qui ont changé bien sûr et
j'assume
depuis le début du mandat j'ai créé 300
nouveaux projets et quand vous êtes élu
pour engager le changement il ya des
choses qui changent et quand vous avez
une baisse des dotations de l'état de
77% et que vous n'augmentez pas les
impôts locaux
eh ben il est donc il faut avoir une
meilleure gestion des deniers publics et
donc on regarde le coût de la dépense
par rapport au nombre d'utilisateurs et
donc nous avons préféré rayon rang avec
1 se nomme de dépenses pour que cela
concerne beaucoup plus de monde
notamment par exemple maurepas estivale
qui crée du lien l'été pour les familles
qui ne peuvent pas partir en un an
vacances c'est 4000 enfants qui sont
concernés
et ça coûte dix mille euros par an les
colonies dont vous parliez ça coûte et
40000 euros par an pour 20 enfants voilà
on fait on fait le choix d'investir
davantage pour pour l'enfance et pour
ceux qui ne partent pas en vacances
amour portman en train de seconde comme
vous approchez vous aurez chacun deux
minutes pour conclure merci ben en fait
faudra expliquer au comité de ville par
exemple aux cartes et des friches toutes
les propositions que vous avez fait
parce qu'ils les voient pas et le comité
de ville d'ailleurs ne fonctionne pas à
tel point que tous ces algériens
concitoyens merci à tel point que tous
les résidents à tel point que tous les
membres qui étaient dedans auditionné
donc ce qui pose problème donc les
mesures
la population ne le voit ne l'avait
relaté par la ville et quand vous allez
au aux friches puisque c'était ce comité
était essentiellement ferry pour ce
quartier là un certain nombre
d'habitants
le deal se sentent complètement exclu ce
qui n'existait pas auparavant par
rapport à un certain nombre de mesures
justement comme je le disais sur les
colonies ou sur la sécurité qui est
complètement je veux dire un délicat
tant sur ses quartiers à non non il va
dire ça mais ça vanne ben je le dis pas
le quartier des friches et un des
quartiers les plus tranquilles de nos
reportages et les statistiques vous êtes
chez nous ben oui j'ai fait partie du
comité jeunesse de sécurité je vous ai
demandé au conseil municipal de nantes
on ne peut pas vous donner ces éléments
l'état c'est trop facile mais non c'est
trop facile le clspd c'est trop facile
non je suis misogyne valenciennes je ne
pouvais pas dire ça c'est une
schématisation quinté des friches
on ne peut pas dire qu'il ya de la
sécurité en éducation des filles qui
sait mayenne ismaïl avait évoqué comme
vous pouviez pas sur vidic est excellent
je demande qu'on n'a pas et demander à
madame la commissaire
il faut aller sur le quartier des
fichiers vous ouvrirez ce que diront les
gens là je viens de bien terminer deux
semaines de porte à porte aux friches
nous n'avons pas de délinquance aux
friches au contraire en plus nous avons
des caméras de surveillance vous n'avez
décès enregistrés nous avons soit nous
avons tous sauf moi c'est monsieur vous
pouvez pas dire ça parce que si je vous
maîtrisez les habitants bull avait dit
il ya aujourd'hui capables de nous avons
nous les avons quelques fait de temps en
temps ça nous plaît nous ont montré que
nous avons quelques scènes de temps en
temps mais vous ne pouvez pas dire que
il ya de la sécurité aux frais
judiciaires enregistrées pour jordan
vous ne connaissez pas vos 10 le ferai
bien je vous dis je vous avais pas plus
avancé localisé en deux secondes juste
de dire là dessus que moi je ne fais pas
une politique sociale uniquement pour un
quartier je fais pour que connaissent
pas c'est vous c'est ce que vous dites
j'ai besoin qu'on a tous les deux vous
êtes quasiment à égalité vous avez vous
avez 20 secondes d'avancé dans les gares
et votre conclusion sera un tout petit
peu plus courte dans les minutes 40 au
nez des deux minutes deux minutes pour
conclure pour vous ismaïl avait rigolé
guerre ici on commence avec vous donc
pour cette conclusion à ce débat du
premier tour sur maurepas vous avez vous
le disais une minute 40 à peu près non
la volonté voilà c'est de continuer
d'agir pour pour la nôtre belleville
démord pas moi je
suis né j'y ai vite depuis 37 ans je ne
viens pas seulement là tous les
week-ends je pense que les morlaisiens
ont appris à me connaître je suis
présent très régulièrement à leurs côtés
je suis à leur écoute on fait beaucoup
de choses avec les habitants nous avons
développé énormément d'actions pour 300
nouveaux projets nous souhaitons
continuer avec une nouvelle feuille de
route qui s'appelle maurepas 2030 avec
90 nouvelles propositions pour continuer
sur la réussite scolaire
la rénovation des écoles jeudi l'école
de l'allemagne ne donne que nous
souhaitons rénover la transition
écologique mais aussi la tranquillité
des habitants est évidemment de livrer
le centre aquatique intercommunal en
2022 et je suis entouré d'une nouvelle
équipe une équipe renouvelée à plus de
50%
avec l'expérience de mes élus sortants
et le renouvellement des compétences et
je suis en tout cas très heureux de
cette nouvelle liste et on le verra dans
quelques jours avec beaucoup de
personnalités du monde associatif et du
monde médical et de la société civile
qui me soutiennent avec des médecins
vétérinaires mais aussi des présidents
d'association qui m'ont rejoint pour
continuer d'agir pour maurepas c'est à
vous donc notre projet il est essentiel
le socle de notre projet c'est la
transition écologique qui irradie tout
les autres thématiques de la vie de la
cité
c'est le socle parce que nous sommes
dans un monde un moment qui le demandent
et c'est notre adn c'est vraiment notre
culture et nous souhaitons aller
beaucoup plus loin de ce que pas de ce
qui se fait aujourd'hui par la majorité
actuelle
c'est aussi une volonté d'apaisement
puisque cette majorité elle divise je le
disais tout à l'heure vous donner des
chiffres ont conseil municipal je
demande régulièrement les chiffres où je
demande régulièrement des dossiers il ya
obstruction et vous le dites vous même
dans les nouvelles de versailles où
votre adjoint s'en prend à votre gestion
sur la piscine attaques personnelles
monsieur van bonnes nouvelles
conclusions mais votre parler des
conséquences
restiez parle je précise quand grégory
grâce à raconter son temps par on a donc
voila vous aurez même temps parler si ce
n'est juste forcément si vous vous ai
blessé certains dossiers ça m'a redonné
sait pas quand pas les nouvelles de
versailles semaine dernière voilà c'est
pas des attaques gratuites dans lequel
vous dites vous même que votre ado vous
lui faites pas confiance parce qu'ils
donnent des informations à l'opposition
ce qu'il faut et 2 ce qui démontre
vraiment votre état d'esprit puisque
nous sommes quand même dans une
république et démocratie
l'opposition a droit a accès accéder à
tous les éléments du dossier
on nous dit de faux et vous le désirez
l'entendre que nous sommes vraiment dans
une volonté d'apaisement de transition
écologique de renouvellement d'une
gouvernance nouvelle avec l'implication
pleine et entière des citoyens et je
vous invite le 27 février prochain à la
présentation de ce projet et a contribué
massivement ce nouvel élan pour refaire
un nouveau dynamisme dans notre ville
qui s'est endormi durant ces années
merci à deux secondes près vous êtes à
égalité merci d'avoir joué je marchais
tous les deux je rappelle que toutes les
listes qui sont déclarés en ce 9 février
date de cette émission en direct ont été
sollicités merci à vous de l'émission
est à revoir en replay sur notre site
internet à très bientôt sur tv fil sur
tv soixante dix huit pour un nouveau
débat de premier tour
[Musique]